Mary Kay Cabot Browns beat writer for
Cleveland calm and the Plain Dealer kind
enough to join us Mary Kay would you
make up Johnny manziel's comments
yesterday well you know I rolled my eyes
at the comments you know that I heard
him make on your show as far as blaming
the brown the blaming brian hoyer
because it was more of the same it was
the the judgmental bit that I knew and
then I was familiar with when I was you
know covering him in 2014 and 2015 and I
thought this is not a good sign and then
when I saw that he kind of came back on
Twitter and he retracted and basically
said you know it was all my fault
you know I think that you know he
realized we said wasn't going to help
him and he's been to try to get back
into the NFL so I'm glad to see him
reversed field on that but you know I
didn't like the fact that he was trying
to especially bring Brian Hoyer I talked
to Brian Hoyer at the Super Bowl and you
know he said a lot of things about what
went on that year with Johnny Manziel
that were illuminating as well is there
any truth to what Manziel is saying that
he wasn't prepared that nobody was
helping him you know he he was lazy any
of this actually you know come to mind
and say yeah that was actually the way
it was when he got in there well you
know what and there was a lot of Curt's
of what he said in terms of the Browns
you know really not inventing him
properly they did not do a very good job
at all that year they had great farmer
was the GM he was way in over his head
if you recall they drafted Justin
Gilbert and Johnny in the first round
that year and they were both train
wrecks and they did not do their
homework on those guys so he's very
right in that regard but then when you
spin it forward a little bit to the
point where he blames the Browns for him
being lazy for him you know for them not
helping him well you know what it's time
to put your big-boy pants on when you
get to the NFL I mean he didn't need
brain Hoyer to hold his hand brain learn
from Tom Brady from observing from
watching Tom Brady wasn't always you
know sitting over the playbook with
Brian Hoyer that's now not how it works
and that's not how Brian Hoyer learned
how to mentor he had enough on his plate
trying to figure out
how to get some victories in Cleveland
which he ultimately did do but you know
it wasn't his job you know to take
Johnny by the hand and show me the way
by the time you get to the NFL you know
what you have to do because you've
talked to other quarterbacks you know
you've talked to your agent you've
talked to people so I did not like the
fact that he was trying to blame Brian
and to a certain extent at that point
the Browns for him being lazy I I will
add that they did not do it the violence
did not do a good job of handling what
they what was obviously going on with
Johnny in 2014 they did not I mean I
remember Mike Pettine you know laughing
it off when we would ask them well so
hey Johnny dr. Las Vegas you know this
weekend and you say hey you know
whatever good you know good for you
Johnny I mean it was just they enabled
and they turned a blind eye to what was
obviously obviously going on with Johnny
that year which as you know as a media
we were all over it I mean we were all
over it and took a lot of heat for it
actually but it was so evident that you
know that he was struggling with with
substance abuse even at that time and
you know and I don't think the Browns
did a great job of managing that or just
the whole Johnny Manziel for not do the
Browns have to take a quarterback this
year up top you know I think they do I
really think they do there are so many
people don't want to see them take fake
ones Berkeley there but they can't do
that I mean they have not taken a
quarterback above 22 to 10,000 1999 they
really have to go QB with their first
pick overall now whether or not they
swap that with the Giants or whatever
they do their first selection has to be
a quarterback they have to find the one
that they love in this draft and just go
grab that guy who do you think it's
going to be so hard right now a lot of
mixed signals going out there but I
think if I had to make a guess right now
I would still say stands Arnold but I do
think that these visits are you know
they're really anything have to kind of
make their final determination and I'm
sure there will still be some good
healthy debate going on but the the
difference in this front office to the
previous one
that you have a new GM how is Dorsey
handling this it feels like they're a
lot more they're quieter and it you know
that they're not leaking stuff out and I
understand that that's advantageous if
somebody else wants to go up and thinks
they're gonna take Sam darn 'old or they
want to get Sam darn old but what's
different about about this front office
that you feel a little more confident in
well because they had experience I mean
you can just look into that front office
and see that there are people there who
have been around good quarterbacks who
have been part of drafting really good
quarterback you know what they're
looking at we have a track record of
talent evaluation and that's the
difference it's really the first time
that I can remember and you know since
I've been covering team for a while a
long time that they had really this
strong of a fun office across the board
and I really think that you know they're
on the right track in terms of just
bringing in big football players I mean
people talk all the time about a culture
change I think that is so over is a
culture change happens when you spin up
a roster with really good football
players and they go out and I love Tyrod
Taylor bringing him in he doesn't turn
the ball over I don't know it was this a
popular decision you know it is a
popular decision in Cleveland today I do
think that you know Browns fans you know
are always looking for hope things
eternal at this time of year in Browns
town you know it's Super Bowl time for
Cleveland with the draft coming up but
you know I think that people need to be
cautiously optimistic when I talk to
people in Buffalo you know they didn't
want him back for some reason and you
know I think that people have to be
cautiously optimistic about what Tyrod
Taylor can bring because if he was going
to be a savior for sure then Buffalo
would not have let him walk out the door
so hopefully they can surround him with
a lot of parents and a really good
defense and some nice pieces coming out
of this dress support him and every way
that they can and get the best out of
here well I think you should break you
know it's the new phrase sweeping the
NFL the the bridge quarterback I because
I don't know if you're if if you draft
Sam Darnell - Sam Donald
in Cleveland no I mean Tyrod Taylor did
the plan is to at least start him for
all of 2018 now of course how often does
that happen one quarterback makes this
very entire shoot but that's the plan
and that's all the way they brought in
Drew Stanton because they don't want Sam
Donald going in in week 2 if Tyrod
Taylor gets a concussion they do not
want that so they will plug through in
there at that point and they are going
to let their want to let Sam develop I
mean Hugh Jackson is coming off of Owen
8 with Cody Kessler in 2016
Owen 15 with another rookie in DeSean
Kaiser and if you'll notice Kevin Hogan
had been granted permission to seek a
trade so that would mean all three
quarterbacks from last year would have
been traded away and they went into
their own 16 season without a
quarterback who had ever won a football
game as a starter and with only one who
had ever started one talking to Mary Kay
Cabot be a Cleveland Browns writer for
the Cleveland Cleveland calm Cleveland
Plain Dealer I'll leave you with this
when Mary Kay would you rather cover a
really good team or really bad - you
know what I will call you I mean think
about it the Browns are always in the
news I think I actually have not minded
I mean for the sake of Browns pants I
would like to see the Browns get this
turned around but it's not been it
hasn't been horrible as if some people
might think it's not you know depressing
or anything I take myself you know out
of that equation and just cover the news
and there's plenty of it and you could
January off because they're never in the
playoffs I don't get any right now we
are we have two days off in June that I
can think of maybe June 24th of trying
to keep doing a great job Mary Kay we
appreciate your time thank you thanks
for having me
that's Mary Kay cannon covers the
Cleveland Browns for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you
[Music]